hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we are
looking at upgrading some doodads and
doohickeys not gonna upgrade the javelin
what is the alt fire even do I don't
even know not gonna upgrade that until I
know that I'm going to keep it I know
I'm keeping the detonator and the line
gun because they're awesome line gun is
if he pried good for groups but I
haven't gotten them all coming running
at me all at once but so I'll just go
plain and simple
can't go wrong with upgrading the stasis
I can tell them I'm actually gonna be
using the stasis a lot more in this game
because obviously it's hard difficulty I
need to be a little more time have you
more tactically oriented is this deal
thank you I couldn't tell with the
floating bodies very more explodey do
hangs hello locked who needs an elevator
when you're in zero gravity I suppose
have you ever seen fire in zero gravity
it's beautiful really oxygen station
there's oxygen oh no they're going to
take it away I know
am I supposed to take a fire oxygen take
away the oxygen in the fire obviously it
was so obvious would fish flying through
the air
oh god how do I orient to ground control
control shift shift of the boost oh god
how do i or z ah see goodies
yeah there any secret goodies up here
seems like there would be at all secret
goodies or goodies yeah my dad oriented
ground I can't get away from how cool
this is
oh and I just saw the Dead Space 3
trailer and I have to admit it's kind of
a take away from what I thought poor
would be in this game it looks more like
an action game than anything else which
is disappointing to say the least
alright no Austin ah what's that shadow
you see reason yeah whatever
Oh goodies I have one and it is already
upgraded from the dead space version oh
okay wonky wonk wonk Ewok okay a shoe a
shoe that I never knew you what what was
the hell is that
I don't whatever I gotta go ah what the
hell oh baby you get them I'm not
another one I can't die it can't die
don't make me die where the babies come
no aha
xuxa [ __ ] through sure yeah shooted a
shoe another one you're dead stay dead
give me that I got plenty of us Oh - I'm
gonna Olson Oh see I've had it up to
here with the OSI well whatever you're
out of here
oh god there's no oxygen in here oh I
need to get oxygen like real bad ah get
power power power power power power
gimme I need to get ice mint that room
ah
nope not gonna done there we go
yeah I'm depressed I'm so great oh no
god I can't okay
sorry my awesomeness almost got the best
I handled it
yeah spike through you I did not shoot a
spike it did I
I did not whatever for those anyways
those were in Dead Space 1 or they just
bought batteries or they engines I don't
know authorized engineers only that's me
that was good that was good oh really
good huh oh man Oh does it have two legs
you're three legs what the hell is going
on there you seeing that it's got like
three leg oh man
that's scared the Dickens out of me oh I
haven't it that's good because that's
like the first good scare that I've
gotten in this game too far between
defense he wants me to follow the steps
hop 1 crawl into the dork machine that's
awesome
can't hurt she wants me to go into the
dark machine Isaac can't go she's in
there
she's waiting for me straw so she got oh
God sauce listen to me Nina came over
can we get to the Train can you do that
can you do that you kill me
can't talk can't talk is he talking
about
Nichole
you see her - okay
lots of dead bodies but not enough
Necromorphs or not plenty of macropores
I'm just saying it's a bit quiet and all
they had they all they threw me was
those two babies huh
oh I see that
come here kiddies I get that goodie from
their help too far out of it oh boy oh
boy oh boy
detonator that nurse saved me home
please save me save me detonator some
stasis over there
Goody's over there
how many how many grenades can you have
out at a time Owen more Dayton endures
I'm guessing they want me to use the
detonator
ah take that come at me Mommy bro oh
yeah ah
Oh pwnage de vich dream can handle how
awesome laughs yeah another one we
didn't eat her mind did I get them all
ha ha now works out beautifully
I love I love love the detonator it is
my favorite gun of all time more than
the pole I love ok I'm not trusting that
that was always crooked angle there
whatever I'm not gonna judge
I think I got all of them
I heard a noise on my window I think
someone's trying to murder eight
probably oh it takes him down in the
order I placed okay Patrick I can
forgive him for that
see I had to open the windows because it
was like boiling hot room hope I'm not
like my screams aren't carrying off to
the neighbors and I wonder is someone
being murdered over there anyway what
times okay plenty of time okay I'm Haven
going the right way
oh man I'm just amazed at how well that
worked out and I'm not gonna do - I'm
not gonna fiddle with this I know
something's gonna come from behind
suddenly themself my neighbors are kind
of far away but I'm wondering if they
can hear me I am kind of loud when I
scream there we go
all right nothing happened yeah me that
yeah all right
goody goody goody thought I heard some
hoes keeping a body all this looks good
how might you start using this wherever
I go because it's way too good to pass
up just going listen the steps can
destroy the marklar skip one scroll into
the dark machine nothing asian-type
all around all right no no no no no no
who's he
I thought he was seeing a girl not a guy
okay nothing so far
I didn't mean there can't be nothing
suspicious
serious [ __ ] whatever it takes
that pen pen pang for is forever is that
supposed to mean
tide men courage compassion stability
and he's probably a Unitologist to say
someone after my own heart
yeah that's awesome ha I don't like it
walk yeah she's like exactly like me
girl tell them oh yeah you are ah no you
stay back you want to talk
you told from there hello baby my name
is ivy oh hello who said that tried to
kill me solving this I'm not gonna hurt
you yeah you got that right you try it
and you're dead uh-huh hey baby
wait up I'm up I'm up I'm gonna come on
yes we die my name's Isaac what I wanted
to stop the quest start here I'm Isaac
hello baby
le le what do you want Isaac
oh no I get to the transport hub I need
to get to the government sector what do
you think we were trying to do who's we
these people that you murdered hey I can
help you
besides we get a better chance if we
stick together don't you agree yeah baby
sorry chance Isaac other people it just
a liability I'll release the door lock
but after that your neurone
and please don't follow me okay uh wait
wait okay
I'll probably see you later he probably
important character and she's so fine
blood eyebrows you interesting given the
the previous history with you know women
and trusting them was it was a lady's
name in disgrace one I don't even
remember now hello big guy is this the
same place I was how did she get here
pulse rounds for my favor gun now my new
favorite gun is now the launcher deadly
grenade launcher
either way it's awesome okay sorry why
don't I do it off I'm falling her she
told me not to follow her but I'm like a
some creepy stalker guy or I'm just
persistent ladies
okay space Tigers that moved what's the
hell's on oh it's one of those things I
hear another one
well there's lon epic okay not bad
okay the ceilings like super low but I
can suck on it okay I mean ever met got
it yeah yeah and their net then kill you
can do it again on that good yeah oh
come on fine
okay you ready now you're ready there
you go you deserve that ha Oh Rebecca ha
there you go
much more better alright
that's a Clio all the time I got for now
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always Oh see you in the next part
bye bye